- But Kelly,
can we sing a song for you?
- Yes, what?
I would, I would be so...
- Hold on, hold on.
Before you do that.
- What?
- Hold, let me grab something real quick.
- Oh my.
- Yeah, you get,
you carry that.
(audience cheers)
Mm hmm.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
- [Kelly] Oh my god, with the harmony.
♪ Happy birthday to you. ♪
♪ Happy birthday dear Kelly ♪
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
(audience cheers)
- Happy birthday!
- That was my fave...
- Yes.
- Like other than my
children singing it to me,
that is my favorite
version ever sung to me.
That was so beautiful, those harmonies.
- They live in Georgia?
- Ah, yes, in Georgia.
- Hey, y'all in Georgia, right?
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna be playing
some shows down there,
I'm gonna have my manager reach out.
I want you guys to open the show for me
when I come to Atlanta.
- Oh my god.
(happy screams)
- So I'm gonna find Dave,
Dave's gonna get with y'all.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, I love y'all.
- They sing so beautiful,
I told you, the harmonies are crazy.
- Y'all great.
- I have never heard
Happy Birthday like that, y'all.
This is so beautiful and it's
gonna make my pants tight.
Okay, thank you to Kelly Gray Cakes.
This is awesome, thank
you, it's beautiful.